[Music]
[Music]
thus the merely eternal or abstract
spirit becomes an other to itself or
enters into existence and directly into
immediate existence accordingly it
creates a
world this creating is picture
thinking's word for the notion itself in
its absolute movement or to express the
fact that the simple which has been
asserted as absolute or pure thought
just because it is abstract is rather
the
negative and hence the self-opposed or
other of itself or
because to put the same thing in another
form that which is posited as essence is
simple immediacy or being but qua
immediacy or being lacks self and
therefore lacking inwardness is passive
or
being for another
this being for another is at the same
time a world spirit in the determination
of being for another is the inert
subsistence of the moments formerly
enclosed within pure thought is
therefore the dissolution of their
simple universality and the parting
asunder of them into their own
particularity
paragraph
774 is introducing a very important
modality let's call it or content
of representation or picture thinking
namely the creation
of a world which is going to get
expanded further in the next paragraph
and you know we've had a lot of we could
say
world building in
past dynamics and dialectics throughout
the phenomenology i mean you can think
back to the spirit section and the
you know engagement with ancient greek
religion and
drama you know the the conflict between
the laws of the city and the the
political authority and the
family and the gods and all that
included a world right
and we had
you know world being important in the
earlier phases of religion but here
we're talking about
the
creation or creating a shaft and
sort of a technical term right within
jewish and christian theology of of a
world right uh you generally understood
as
uh you know x nihilo and all that sort
of stuff but hegel's not so worried
about that here he's more interested in
the
idea of creation here
and he starts out by saying the merely
eternal
or abstract spirit becomes an other in
another to itself this is you know stuff
that we've got developed in the previous
paragraphs or enters into existence
and directly into immediate existence so
you know a few interesting things to
point out right there right
the
spirit the mind the geist
which is eternal which is abstract
abstract as opposed to the concrete or
living or dynamic uh he tells us two
things here it becomes other to itself
okay nothing really that mind-blowing
about that we've been talking about that
endlessly for paragraph after paragraph
and throughout the entire phenomenology
the second part i think is a bit more
interesting enters into existence
twit is from tretin
is the enters it steps into
dazzain into existence
and what miller is translating here as
directly
is actually the same term
for
immediate or in an unmediated
way right directly or metal bar into
immediate existence existence is that
same
dozen right and so this is telling us
how it's entering
into existence and
what that existence is like and an
unmitilbar design right an immediate
unmediated
just that's what you got right there at
least for the time being existence
and in doing so in doing these two
things
he tells us that it
is um
creating
a world and so you know
they're shocked right it it creates
a world
and
what does they then tell us about the
world well this is this important phrase
that i've got right here
this creating
right this this uh
making this special form of causality we
could say
is the word
and here he uses vort right uh it is it
is the expression
it is well you know we're gonna get to
are there any like resonances here of
the word
maybe we'll we'll see as we go on
further it's picture thinking's word or
literally the word of
picture thinking what is picture
thinking representation for stellang you
know something we've talked about many
many times
the word of picture thinking
for meaning corresponding
to attempting to
articulate
not quite there but on the way to
the notion the griff the concept
itself zelpst
in its absolute movement
the vegan in german
so creating is
not exactly what it pretends to be you
know the the understanding the doctrine
of creation
of this entire
universe cosmos world whatever you want
to call it
is itself
still within the realm of representation
but it's something quite important it's
on to something right it's expressing
something
about god and so you know here's where
we get to thinking about the the meaning
of this right we've already laid out one
of these
in the creation of the world and then
hegel restates things
twice for us
right so he says that
to express the fact that the simple the
einfach height which has been asserted
is absolute
or pure or pure thought just because it
is abstract so we've got two different
sides of the same thing the simple
asserted is absolute or reina denkin
pure thought
because it's abstract what what do we
know about that
well he tells us
here we go
that um
it is the negative
and hence the
self-opposed
or other of itself
okay this is you know uh not something
as i said earth shaking we've been
seeing this playing itself out over and
over again in previous paragraphs but
it's nice to reaffirm it right and then
he goes on and he says
um or to put the same thing in another
form so he's what he's what's he doing
here he's trying to help us understand
how all of these are really amounting to
the same thing put the same thing in
another form
that which is posited as essence
right is simple immediacy or being
okay and what we've got a lot of
simplicity here we've got immediacy here
we've got you know the absolute we've
got the abstract we've got essence all
on this side
and then what do we find out again
stuff that hegel has previously
developed but now is going to
you know reiterate and then draw
something new out of
because of that it lacks
a self
right
it lacks zelpst and therefore lacking
inwardness
doesn't have an interiority
something to open up it is
passive
what does that mean
that means
that it is being for
another seinfer andres
right and
what is
this being for another he says this
being for another
is at the same time
a world
to be for another in this case
is to be
something that we can go out into and
experience right so the world is for you
could say for god who is the creator of
it and the world is also for us the
phenomenologists
and for the believers the in religion
out there experiencing the world the
world is
for another
for many and anothers you could say
so he goes on and he says
in the determination of
being for another
as as we're making this determinate
um
inner substance of the moments it
formerly enclosed in pure thought
is therefore the dissolution of their
simple universality and the parting
asunder of them into their own
particularity right so there's a
splitting that is going on within this
world that has been created you could
say as a
environment for that to happen and so
you know where is this going we have to
look at
what happens in the next paragraph
but the world is not merely this spirit
cast out and dispersed into the fullness
of natural existence and its external
ordering for since spirit is essentially
the simple self this self is equally
present in the world it is the existence
spirit which is the individual self
which has consciousness and
distinguishes itself as other or as
world from itself
this individual self as at first thus
immediately posited is not yet spirit
for itself it does not exist as spirit
it can be called innocent but hardly
good
before it can in fact be self and spirit
it must first become an other to its own
self
just as the eternal being exhibits
itself as the movement of being
self-identical in its otherness
since this spirit is determined as at
first an immediate existence or as
dispersed into the multifariousness of
its consciousness
its othering of itself is the withdrawal
into itself or self-centeredness of
knowing as such
immediate existence suddenly turns into
thought or mere
sense consciousness into consciousness
of thought and moreover because the
thought stems from immediacy or is
conditioned thought it is not pure
knowledge but thought that is charged
with otherness and is therefore the
self-opposed thought of good and evil
man is pictorially thought of in this
way
that it once happened without any
necessity that he lost the form of being
at one with himself
through plucking the fruit of the tree
of the knowledge of good and evil and
was expelled from the state of innocence
from nature which yielded its fruits
without toil and from paradise from the
garden with its creatures
paragraph
775 picks up right on the heels of the
previous paragraph and we do get some
discussion
of the
world and creation and you know the fact
that this exists
in a mode of representation rather than
the concept but it goes in a kind of
strange direction we might imagine that
you know now that hegel's introduced
this idea he's going to elaborate it
what does the world consist in
and no
something else happens instead which is
just as exciting and interesting and
moves us forward so he tells us
very promisingly right but the world is
not merely
this spirit and here we get this
wonderful phrase
cast out and dispersed into the fullness
of natural existence and its external
ordering now miller is admittedly taking
a few liberties here
cast out and dispersed two words in
place of one for the
verb you know geworfana right um
but not bad right especially since we're
going to get this multiplicity
happening a little bit later in it so
the dispersed kind of fits into that
um cast out right that's that's clearly
there and outside undergo orphana
into now this is where it gets really
interesting so miller has in brackets
and this i don't think there's a bad
gloss here of natural existence because
we have been talking about
existence and you know natural existence
for
hegel you know the world i think
if natural existence happens anywhere
it's in the world
and so it's being cast out into
the fullness in brackets of natural
existence or we could just say into
fullness full stending kite
can mean fullness it means something
like having been
brought to
its
fullness or fulfillment it's a
teleological
word you could say so there's there's
ends orientation kind of built into this
so in this doctrine of creation being
represented in you know traditional
christian uh teachings
there's a kind of fulfillment happening
at the very beginning of things right as
the world is being
generated created actually we shouldn't
say generated because in christian
theology it's the son who's generated
right
so anyway back to
this uh into the fullness and it's
external ordering and ordnance a putting
things
into place this is what spirit is doing
in relation to spirit
as the world
but then he says something
that takes us into a different course so
as a as opposed to
the world we have the
individual self which is also
spirit right existing or zionist
spirit and remember in the last
paragraph we saw that
uh you know thought is going into
existence it steps into existence and
not just any existence but
uh immediately into immediate existence
right so we have the individual self the
eins on the
and here we actually had a pause for a
second
you know we usually think of our our own
self as whatever is
core to us but it's interesting you know
in german and you know there's this is
the case in other languages too
um
self
is a kind of intensificatory
word but it can be it's also referential
it's filled with content we don't know
what this individual
self is and as hegel's pointed out
earlier there's nothing less individual
than talking about the individual right
the eins on the as uh singular is it's
something that you know is in our
language but the concept of
individuality that's something that
actually has to be achieved concretely
as one becomes
a self
doesn't that sound like a little bit
kierkegaardian anyway going on he says
that spirit is essentially the simple
self
this self is equally present
in the world it is existent spirit which
is the individual self which has
consciousness remember that the world
was a
being for an other lacking interiority
passive you know sort of
there for
not the taking so much but to
provide an environment so the individual
self has consciousness and he says
distinguishes itself as other or as
world from itself and he said well how
in the hell does that happen
how does an individual self distinguish
itself
from itself as
world well by interacting with the world
i suppose right by finding itself
through its activities and its
desires and perhaps
also other individual selves or even you
know god in relation to the world as
well there's a rich
set of possibilities
here i think
and so he goes on and he tells us
something about how this individual self
has to
develop
it turns out that this is going to be
tied in with a very important set of
representations
so he goes on and he says this
individual self as at first thus now
notice again
immediately on methyl bar
posited
is not yet spirit for itself right it's
it's lacking something
uh it's also lacking
the explicit articulation of its own
lack as we're going to see
it it's not
it's conscious
but it's not fully conscious
it's not conscious
in the right way of itself as what it is
so he says it does not exist as spirit
and it can be called
innocent
or shuldig
but not good
right so it exists in a state of
uh unsure kite or a lack of literally a
lack of guilt a lack of blame
right but it's not good because of that
and this is something that we should
dwell on for a minute thinking about
this um you know
to be
innocent in this way
is really more of a
um privation
of the fullness of
human being it's not innocent as in the
sense of like having been found innocent
at trial after you know you've gone
through all this stuff it's just it
hasn't occurred to it right
and
it's going to lose this
fairly
shortly because he says
before it can in fact be self
before it can be what a self is
and spirit the spirit that it is
it must first do something what does it
have to do
well what spirit has been doing in an
abstract way now has to be done in a
individual way a concrete way but also a
way that is sort of like writ large for
all humankind
it has to become an other
to its own self
just as the eternal being exhibits
itself as the movement of being
self-identical in its otherness so all
these things about the the eternal being
uh the you know spirit becoming other to
itself that we've seen in the previous
paragraphs now is happening at the level
of the individual the
poor slob who's out there you know
meandering around in the world trying to
figure things out and figure out who he
or she
happens to be right
so he goes on and he says
since this spirit
is determined
skimped right
at first
as at first an immediate existence or
now here we get that dispersed right
dispersed into the
multifuriousness the monique faulty kite
manifold-ness
of its consciousness its othering of
itself is the withdrawal into itself or
self-centeredness of knowing as such now
this is this is something where we want
to read between the lines a bit
don't we
so
spirit existing as individual self
is not spirit existing as an single
individual self it is spirit existing as
a multifariousness
which is not just lining up a plurality
of individuals each in a row each
individual just like
every other individual
no it's not going to that's not going to
work that's not going to get us what we
want
we have a genuine plurality here a
multifariousness of individuals how are
these individuals connected with with
themselves
and with uh the other individuals is it
only by being instantiations of spirit
in a particular world no and here's
where we have to read between the lines
all the previous stuff about
consciousnesses self-consciousness is
reasons spirits encountering each other
has to be read in here
human beings
exist in relation to their other they
don't just become other to themselves
they find that other that is themselves
in the other
or others who are other cells as well
and this is where things can go wrong in
many many ways right
you can subordinate the other and you
you don't get what you want from them
the recognition
you know there's all sorts of uh
detours we can take so that that's a
little bit of an aside but i think one
that's quite important to keep in the
background
here so
dispersed into the multi-fairness of its
consciousness
it's othering of itself
is withdrawal into itself
or
self-centeredness being centered upon
this self that you're trying to unpack
and discover
of knowing
as such
so there's a very important
transformation taking place here
immediate existence when mitchell bars
design
what we were finding in the previous
paragraph right
immediate existence suddenly turns into
thought
and
um
mere self-con sends consciousness into
consciousness
of thought
and moreover because the thought
stems from immediacy
or is conditioned thought it is not pure
knowledge
but the thought now this is a
incredible line
thought
that is charged with otherness is how
miller translates it i like that
translation a little bit more literally
on design on
hot right that has
being other than itself in
inside of itself
um
charged with otherness though like like
an electrical charge right or charged as
in you know laden down with otherness on
its back
or connected with it you know these are
all nice images aren't they
images of course
are
for stellogen so we're
moving into
our own little representations here
based on this language and i leave it up
to you to decide whether that's you know
suitable or not
all right so let's go on it's not pure
knowledge but thought that is charged
with otherness
and is therefore a special a special
kind of thought a special content of
thought but it's not just a content it's
also a form right self-opposed thought
right and here the the self-opposed is
zelpst and gegen gazettes this could be
translated as an antithetical thought
right or oppositional
thought
what is that thought
it is of good
good
and evil
so before in the state of innocence no
good
also no evil
here
the self
within the world
within this multiplicity of individual
selves
comes to understand
good and evil
and now notice what hegel says here
here's where we're getting to the
representation
man is pictorially thought of in this
way man is you know for gestalt man is
uh represented
in this way
represented who to man to human beings
this is how human beings tell a story
about themselves and what is the story
here it is about you know the the
genesis story about how human beings
screwed it up
in the middle of the garden of eden
there was just one thing they weren't
supposed to do
eat of that tree over there which turns
out to be the tree of the knowledge of
good and evil right and there's a couple
characters involved there's a there's a
guy adam there's a girl eve and they're
happy together and you know adam maybe
with eve maybe without has named all the
animals and everybody's living a nice
hunky-dory life in paradise right
everybody's got their place and then the
serpent comes along and it's not the
serpent that we know today because you
know after the serpent is cursed he
loses
his legs and has to crawl in the dust
and you know you know the story i hope
right and if you don't well you know
look it up because it's a it's a very
rich
foreshadowing of you know how things
went wrong right there's many stories
out there about how human beings screwed
it up but i like this one in particular
because we don't have just one
individual self you know
in adamson all men fell no it's adam and
eve screwing it up and there's also this
tempter
screwing it up and they don't know about
the consequences of what they're doing
until they take that fateful step and
you know eat the fruit by the way it's
not an apple it's just mentioned as a
fruit a lot of people
biblical scholars think it might be a
quince for all that matter but it
doesn't the content of what kind of
fruit it is it's a fruit that tells you
good from evil maybe not perfectly
reliably but you certainly have a sense
of it
and once you know
that good and evil are involved
the whole world changes
and you change
right you can't go back
you can try to
deny it
you can tell yourself comforting stories
you can get drunk all the time or high
all the time and you know try to
drown your your troubles as we say but
you can't really ultimately
get away from it and this is a very
important development so he says
man is pictorially thought of in this
way that it once happened without
without any necessity didn't have to go
that way
that he lost the form of being at one
with himself
through plucking the fruit of the tree
of the knowledge of good and evil notice
that hegel for hegel it's not even
tasting it just plucking it is enough
right
and was expelled from the state of
innocence
from nature which yielded its fruits
without toil and from paradise from the
garden with its creatures so the world
the earth
no longer gives its bounty to the human
beings
and the animals have now a different
relation as life as kinds of life uh the
multifairness of life have a different
relationship to human beings and you
can't get away from this good and evil
at this point now hegel is saying that
is a representation that's a
foreshadowing it's not a
conceptual depiction of what's going on
i'm trying to provide that to you here
in the phenomenology but it is helping
to get us
on the way so to speak
you